céline n'écoute personne depuis que rené
mans mais quand on dit personne même pas
de doute jean paul houde georges marie
et rené amazonie de rabat c'est ce que
vous faites devant enfin plus souvent
des comme cela qu'on aime ça c'est les
mettre aux jeunes chantaient sommes un
jour là bas le chanteur
peut-être que ça y est resté dans ta
tête mais c'est son choix et moi je vais
chanter cette chanson à 2894 fois je
m'en suis jamais lassé et peut-être ça
va devenir une chose tu as peur pour
elle son maillot et parce que c'est laid
comme moi va jamais s'en lasser puis
tous les jours ça va devenir de plus en
plus shakespearien si elle s'en va dans
la simplicité partent assez instinctive
balas et de musicalité